saitama he goes by many different names
in pop culture bald Cape Cape Baldy the
one punch man but rarely do you hear him
being called hero a common conversation
topic I've heard discussed over the last
number of years is beam is Saitama
really a hero with this question in mind
I decided to take to my Twitter to ask
my followers their opinions on this
controversial character asking do you
think Saitama is heroic with over 3,000
votes cast the results were just as
divided as I expected with the comment
section below demonstrating an even more
conflicted outlook many exclaiming
absolutely not and other screaming yes
of course he is so today I want to take
this as an opportunity to analyze and
breakdown the character and personality
of one of animes most popular modern
protagonists a character that's viewed
by some as lazy and uninspired and by
others inspirational and complex all in
an effort to determine if he is in fact
an heroic figure today I want to analyze
and breakdown one punch man's main
protagonist
[Music]
before we talk about saitama's heroism
or lack thereof I think it's important
we first define what makes for a heroic
act km Weiland author of creating
character arcs defines it as the hero
puts himself out there and gives up
something major and personal often his
own life in order to achieve a goal or
saved someone else
in other words sacrifice personal or
otherwise seems to play an important
role in defining an heroic act
typically this character finds
themselves in a number of familiar
situations most depicting the hero with
his back against the wall fighting for
what he thinks is right regardless of
the dangers associated and seeing as one
punch man deals with superhero tropes
specifically let's take a look at the
film Captain America the First Avenger
acting as the prime example of what I
think most people might agree on is the
definition of aneroid figure in pop
culture Captain America in this film is
certainly not short of his fair share of
heroic moments the most obvious being
its ending as cab makes the difficult
decision to crash the plane he's flying
to save the world choosing to end his
own life for the greater good losing
everything important to him in the
process however I think the best example
of aneroid moment from the film is this
this is a terrific example of a scene
that shows off exactly what many would
argue are important to tributes in
making your hero a hero without delay
casting yourself into harm's way in
order to preserve the well-being of
someone other than yourself an
altruistic act of good a common argument
I've heard is that Saitama a person
that's resilient to the point of being
near indestructible cannot have a scene
like this he can't be brave like Captain
America or spider-man because unlike
them he isn't physically threatened by
anything and therefore can't sacrifice
his physical well-being for the good of
others and that's absolutely true
but it wasn't always the case in one of
the very few glimpses we get as readers
into saitama's past we see a powerless
young disillusioned man apathetic in his
struggle to find a job confronted by a
monster seemingly for the first time in
his life he puts up no fight to protect
his own life once threatened the monster
explains that he is after someone else
and moves along without harming Saitama
on his journey home he encounters the
child that the crab monster is after
before long the crab monster arrives in
the scene to confront the child in front
of Saitama ready to kill him without
thinking Saitama throws himself in
harm's way saving the child's life he
decides in that moment to pursue his
childhood dream of becoming a hero that
defeats villains and he does just that
however in that pursuit he loses the
ability to be physically vulnerable to
attack which is the most common threat
to be issued to a hero by a villain as a
result if the modern Saitama was put
into the same position again it wouldn't
have the same tone or sense of danger
and sacrifice thus losing its air of
heroism and the author of one punch man
was aware of that which is why we have
characters like jenos that exemplify a
more traditional power set and moral
compass dealing with situations for the
good of others even in the face of
absolute destruction however does this
mean that because of Saitama seemingly
invulnerable state of being it's fair to
say that since gaining his powers he
hasn't done anything nor is he capable
of doing anything heroic no in Robert
McKee's book story
he writes story is about archetypes not
stereotypes the archetypal story on
earth a universally human experience
then wraps itself inside a unique
culture specific expression a
stereotypical story reverses this path
it suffers the poverty of both content
and form it can find itself to a narrow
culture specific experience and dresses
in stale nonspecific generalities in
other words it's the characters and
their arcs that should dictate the
scenes that are created not the other
way around
and so because certain genres produce
stories that often portray certain
characters in specific ways when an
author writes their story they might
feel compelled to shoehorn their
characters into specific scenes they
have in mind to create scenes or story
beats that are more familiar to the
viewers or readers or put more simply
forcing tropes in unnatural ways an
example of this misuse of character can
be observed in the film Suicide Squad
we're a group of villains of varying
expertise and ability are thrown into a
situation they wouldn't naturally choose
to be in however the issue with this
story becomes abundantly clear when
characters like Harlequin Killer Croc
and the rest of the team decide to save
the day at the end not because it makes
sense for their characters to come to
that conclusion but because that's what
happens at the end of these kinds of
films it's a classic case of stereotypes
driving the narrative instead of
character let's go if the area's Suicide
Squad failed I think one punch man seems
to have its strengths first show that
deals with supernatural heroes and
monstrous characters on a regular basis
it never loses itself in the stereotypes
and pitfalls of the genre embracing that
side only when it makes sense or if a
joke is being made
midway through the first season a
character by the name of the deep-sea
king is introduced as he wreaks havoc on
a city claiming the lives of many and
taking out numerous impressive heroes
along the way right as the last line of
defense for the citizens of the city is
crushed Moomin writer a regular man
trying to do the right thing having
traveled miles by bicycle arrives to
help in whatever way he can the
characters watching in the background
and all of us watching from our homes
know that he doesn't stand a chance and
in possibly one of the most moving
moments of the series we watch a man
humble himself both physically and
verbally because he knows that giving
everything he has to protect people is
the right thing to do the devastated and
frightened crowd turned to roaring
support and applause as they cheer for
Moomin Ryder barely standing he uses the
support of the people to psych himself
up for one last great
Yoga nice cycle in this scene Saitama
demonstrates that he is an heroic figure
in ways no other character has been
before in the story to help us fully
understand how one punch man's author
one achieves this we must first
understand the term dramatic irony in
Robert McKee's book story he explains in
dramatic irony the audience knows more
than the character's dramatic irony
creates interest primarily through
concern alone eliminating curiosity
about facts and consequences it
encourages the audience to look more
deeply into the motivations and casual
forces at work in the characters lives
in other words when we the audience know
the outcome of a scene or event we can
more closely pay attention to understand
and appreciate the motivations and
emotional nuances of a scene for
instance in the movie get out directed
by Jordan Peele
upon first viewing we as a viewer can
sense that there is something not quite
right about the Family Rose has brought
her boyfriend Chris to meet and so we
spend quite a bit of time trying to
figure out what the movie isn't telling
us once it's revealed to us what Rose
and her family have in store for Chris
the movie quickly and satisfyingly
reaches its action and suspense-filled
conclusion however upon second viewing
as an audience instead of trying to
figure out what the twists are ending
might be we instead can focus on and
understand the decisions the characters
made along the way to get to the
conclusion a terrific example of what
I'm talking about can be observed with
roses objection to the police officers
request at the beginning of the film to
see Chris's identification upon first
viewing it might appear as though she is
standing up for her boyfriend however it
is in fact her working to avoid a paper
trail being created for the authorities
to follow once chris eventually is
brainwashed by her family if you know
how the scene episode or film ends
before the character does then that is
dramatic irony this is why we enjoy a
film or show more or at least
differently on a second viewing instead
of trying to make sense of what's
happening we can instead focus on
understanding empathizing and dread what
the characters are about to experience
in the case of this particular one punch
man scene there are two important
aspects of the story at play one Saitama
kills the deep-sea King before going
into the altercation we as Vee
know that Saitama is jealous of Genesis
adulation and success with the public
Saitama wants to feel appreciated and
actively goes out of his way to seek
recognition and appreciation earlier in
the story however right after Saitama
kills the deep-sea King the scene skips
the future as both jenos and himself are
opening letters they have received the
mail
amid dozens of fan letters janice has
again received Saitama is excited to
find out that he has won - at this point
we have been led to believe that this
will in fact be a fan letter considering
the great service Saitama provided by
protecting the large crowd from the deep
sea king
however moments later we find out that
it reads no one cares about you you
cowardly cheating bastard this now acts
as the lens for which we viewed the
subsequent flashback of events we now
understand the conclusion and so we can
now focus on the motivations and choice
is made to get to this point once the
letter is shown we return back after the
deep-sea Kings to feed as the crowd
erupts with tears of joy for Saitama as
quickly as it began an individual in the
crowd begins rationalizing that if a
ranked sea hero like Saitama was able to
do what the s-class at a class heroes
couldn't and the hero Association must
be a fraud and doesn't deserve the tax
money they received from the public
overhearing all of this Saitama without
skipping a beat begins gloating and
thanking all of the heroes for their
hard work in softening the villain up
for him he exclaims that now he can
continue to take credit for their hard
work
Saitama in this moment chose to deny
himself the appreciation and respect he
deeply desires and deserves in favor of
preserving an association that refuses
to acknowledge him but one that the
people need to protect them from the
creatures that lurk in wait heroism is
the throwing a sign of things that you
care about in favor of doing the right
thing for others sacrifice as common as
it is in superhero stories usually
manifests itself in the hero putting
himself into life-threatening danger
struggling against a great evil
achieving heroic feats using their
spectacular powers however somewhat
ironically Saitama a hero with power
beyond comprehension manages to become a
hero in a way all of us watching have
the power to be there are many other
instances in the story where Saitama
provides selfless service to those that
do not appreciate him and to those that
do to ask for his help but a hero is not
limited by what is asked of him but what
he asks of himself one punch man reminds
us that sometimes being a
can be as simple as choosing to say a
difficult thing for the right reasons
for a character with abilities as
fantastical and overstated as sigh
Thomas it's ironic to see that his
heroism is not only understated but when
compared to the rest of the heroes that
inhabit the pages of shounen jump and
beyond is both minimized and
unconventional it's made abundantly
clear in the source material that
Saitama is at everyman traditionally
unintelligent and somewhat lazy but on
the rare occasions that he is faced with
issues his powers do not equipment for
he proves time and time again that not
only is he a remarkable character but
also an heroic one thanks for watching
[Music]